j'ai une question à vous poser quelle
est la principale cause de votre entrée
en disgrâce l'ignorance la perception
regardez aujourd'hui par exemple avec le
démolisseur situation compliquée vous
avez dû prendre des décisions difficiles
on m'en parlait pas je ne peux pas en
parler parce que je n'ai rien pu voir
personne n'a rien pu voir lorsque vous
combattez les méchants comme aujourd'hui
personne ne voit les combats mais ce qui
les a provoqués on ne voit que ce que
les politiciens pointe du doigt les gens
associent destruction et vous donc si
nous voulons changer la perception que
les gens ont des super héros
il faut que vous partagiez est votre
perception avec le monde entier et
comment fait-on cela avec des caméras en
incrustant de mini caméras comme celle
ci dans vos costumes incroyables ces
tout-petits et l'image est parfaite
merci c'est ma création
tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les a bien séché devenu c'est moi
sinon est ce qu il est prévu qu'on en
parle un jour quoi du sujet tabou
évidemment quel sujet tabou le nouveau
travail de maman il est temps grand
temps de réparer nos erreurs
aidez nous à faire sortir de l'ombre
tous les supers nous devons changer
l'opinion des gens sur les super-héros
et pour cela élastique earl est notre
meilleur atout meilleur que moi
j'adore le nôtre avait deux mamans au
revoir chérie je m'occupe les enfants
pas de problème c'est pas comme ça qu'il
faut faire papa le prof dit qu'on veut
utiliser cette méthode je connais pas
cette méthode est pourquoi ils changent
les maths les maps et les matins mi-mars
s'est fait mal au cou série comment vous
êtes enfin très bien j'ai peur c'est
soit la petite de dolus danse et jack
est très en forme c'est quoi ça ok
jackson waouh
d'accord ça c'est plus bas c'est
complètement fou non pour aider ma
famille et je dois la quitte t il pour
se baigner la loi de la transgresser le
pour nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le choix
merci jeune homme
[Musique]
combustion imminent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
les lotisseurs enterrons ce programme
afin de vous délivrer un message en film
en costumes ça va chauffer j'arrive je
me dépêche
[Musique]